[Musique]
une clope donc savidan grec enfin sauf
paris donc les conférences des parties
197 pays se sont mis d'accord sur l'idée
qu' à chaque année il fallait qu'on se
rencontre pour parler de changement
climatique chaque pays envoie une
délégation
de fonctionnaires de ministres eux mêmes
parfois même un premier ministre qui va
participer à cet événement là pour
négocier pour arriver à des décisions
qui vont permettre de lutter contre les
changements climatiques
donc c'est vraiment comme un mini
village le qui s'anime pendant deux
semaines on a extrêmement intensive
c'est vraiment un moment important
[Musique]
l'homme d'après rio doit aussi aimé le
monde tout cet environnement naturel que
nous détruisons
régulièrement donc en 92 au sommet de la
terre on a eu le principe des
responsabilités communes mais
différenciées de voir comment on va
distribuer l'effort pour lutter conte
des changements climatiques à ce moment
là l'enjeu des changements climatiques
étaient vraiment perçue comme un enjeu
d'une dynamique nord c'est-à-dire les
pays du nord sont beaucoup plus
responsable la problématique et vont
devoir donc réduire leurs émissions et
aider les pays en développement à peu
passer par le même le même modèle l'umq
rapidement on est arrivé avec le
protocole de kyoto à la cadre duquel on
va fixer concrètement ce que les pays
riches doivent pas mais les pays en
développement avaient donc pas
d'obligation de réduction d'émissions de
gaz à effet de serre c'était à une
époque où les pays en développement ne
m'étais pas beaucoup de g us mais depuis
les pays en développement ont énormément
augmenté leurs émissions l'émergence des
baisers crise le brésil l'afrique du sud
l'inde la chine des pays qui sont des
grands pollueurs et des pays qui la
cherche à se développer économiquement
hélas que ça fait sale a commencé à
ébranler cette idée de il ya des pays
riches qui sont responsables des pays
pauvres sont victimes il ya un portrait
qui devient de plus en plus nuancée à
travers ça et bien sûr les etats-unis
eux n'aimais pas cette vision
dichotomique l'heure des états unis ont
quitté le protocole de kyoto le canada a
quitté le protocole de kyoto ce qui a
littéralement ébranlé le régime qui mate
s'économiser après ça on essaye de
réintégrer les états unis dans la
gouvernance mondiale du climat si on
continue comme ça c'est l'échec d'une
première tentative a été faite à
copenhague ce fut un échec lamentable
on a vu que on avait besoin d'une
meilleure stratégie l'accord de paris vi
qui cherche à forcer répondent à cette
dualité l'eau qui était présente entre
les pays riches et les pays pauvres de
faire éclater le moderne pour que tous
les pays puissent contribuer à l'effort
de lutte contre les changements
climatiques à la hauteur de leurs moyens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le traité a été rédigé d'une certaine
manière pour être signées alors c'était
pas des fous ils avaient vraiment en
tête que des pays comme les etats-unis
allaient débarquer si on mettait des
cibles contraignantes
par contre il y avait quand même des
mécanismes que tous les pays se sont
entendus comme justement le fait de
mettre de l'avant des cibles de dire que
nos cibles doivent être plus ambitieuse
à chaque fois à chaque fois et de dire
qu'à chaque 50 on va mettre de l'avant
des nouvelles cibles qui vont être
justement toujours plus ambitieuses que
les précédentes donc c'est peut-être le
meilleur traité qu'on pouvait avoir dans
le contexte
on notera souvent cette impression qu
elle les négociations climatiques avance
à un pote tortue par contre je pense
qu'il faut pas voir les négociations
climatiques et par hasard comme étant
juste l'action des chefs d'état les
chefs de gouvernement pour voir tout ce
qui gravite autour de ça il ya plein de
choses qui avancent à un rythme
extrêmement positif l'avènement des
énergies renouvelables puis la
multiplication des énergies
renouvelables à travers le monde et
quand même un signe en soi qui est
positif alors qu'il ya dix ans on n'en
parlait pas bien de plus en plus par
exemple la question de la décroissance
commence à refaire surface donc oui il
ya des choses qui avancent faut juste
pour regarder tout ce qui se fait en
haut mais voir ce qui se fait à tous les
échelons et là je pense que ça nous
permet de maintenir un espoir que de
continuer à vouloir que ça change
on voit qu'il ya urgence d'agir qu'on
veut qu'elle décide en soit sérieux dans
leurs demandes
donc oui bien sûr on suit avec intérêt
puis on devient rare de voir les
débouchés pour moi c'est comme la fin
d'un épisode d'une saison d'une bonne
série télé glasgow c'est là c'est le
dernier épisode de la saison alors j'ai
quand même hâte si vous avez aimé leur
explication on vous prépare un deuxième
volet à propos de ce qui sera à suivre à
glasgow ça sort dans quelques jours
abonnez-vous à radio canada
environnement sur facebook et sur
instagram